[Music]
Kumail Nanjiani I mean what else do you
have to say I love them and indieWIRE
honors presents the creative
independence award to Brian Henderson
I'm sorry I read that wrong Kumail
Nanjiani look wearing gold like has been
topping everyone's list of their
favorite movies of the year what does
that mean to you I mean it's the start
of award season you're already getting
the recognition we make that face
partially it's lovely
yeah it's hard to still not be like
overwhelmed even yeah movies been out
for a few months it's uh it's been
beyond our wildest hopes and
expectations like to have a story that's
our story and was so personal to us but
also people tell us that it's like
resonating with them and that I mean
that's it's overwhelming and really
really lovely I feel like maybe this is
the best it's ever gonna be for us no
it's just like it is truly hard to go
yeah it's just hard to top is what I
mean yeah as I was saying and I realized
that she knows she's the your deposit
yeah overall I said like we're both
optimistic but you know she is the
flying and I'm the let's not get you
crazy person I want to thank most for
sure is the co-writer and my partner in
everything
Emma levy Gordon without you now what
are the the do's and don'ts of working
with their spouse wow that's a good
question that's hard anytime
do you have a specific base that's like
work space in your house because you
can't turn your bat into work space and
that's different work right yeah that's
different work it's true so there will
be some times where we'd be in bed and
I'd be like hey I want to talk about the
movie can we step into the bathroom like
because we have spaces where we couldn't
and then we also had a rule that was
like we couldn't just if you're working
on something together and you're living
together it's very easy to just talk
about work the whole time so we'd have
to like be like get permission from the
other person to talk about it but I
think and don't wear pants when you
write well I think that's that's the
that's like one of the huge advantages
you don't have to like put on clothes to
work together you can just I work in an
office I have to wear pants when I'm
writing all right yeah we don't have to
yeah but I think it worked really really
well I felt like we complemented each
other's writing really well and we'd you
know we'd work together before we hadn't
written together before but we'd work
together before so so I feel like we've
sort of figured out our system I think
there's something you're passionate
about that you sort of arguing about use
that to inform the work you're doing
rather than like letting that be a road
block we like we ended up using in a lot
of like yeah yeah use it do it that
ended up a lot of time being the
conflict between female and Emily in the
movie was some of the things we were
yeah that's right